la France depuis
Pompidou a travaillé à sa souveraineté
énergétique par la filière nucléaire
c'était une des fiertés de la France
nous étions quasiment au taux suffisant
et à l'arrivée de
François Hollande et même et même avant
sous François Mitterrand et bien il y a
eu une diabolisation du nucléaire et on
a
[Musique]
déraisonnablement fragiliser notre
filière nucléaire et le coup de grâce a
été porté par Emmanuel Macron qui au
début de son premier quinquennat en 2017
a annoncé que la part du nucléaire ne
devait pas excéder 50%. et qu'il fallait
fermer des centrales nucléaires il a
amorcé le mouvement avec la fermeture de
Fessenheim dont les spécialistes disent
que sa mise aux normes pouvait lui
permettre de durer encore 30 ans c'est
vraiment un gâchis épouvantable et dans
la loi aujourd'hui existe toujours la
perspective de la fermeture de plus
d'une dizaine de centrales nucléaires
ajouter à cela que la moitié de nos
centrales en exercice
sont à l'arrêt pour des questions
maintenant
on est aujourd'hui extrêmement